is a difficult one so I'll try to enjoy
um
so you come in and here you're going to
use this arm go towel
this this arm here you're gonna
capture this armor
really hard to find funny with that arm
if you do it physically
yeah
do all sorts of things but not the thing
you want to do
that's what I'm trying to do is come
here bring it over and what I should be
doing
is what Richard was showing that is
my body more
yeah we've got that bit most people
there
you're working on trapping here not
throwing air and Lily's neck if I tap
this arm this arm keep myself
what have you got to hear your client
trap
and see if you can do it by molding your
body rather than trying to get him down
with the sunlight his arm is going to be
difficult I've transfer over this you've
got to do it with your body you'll
notice that here's that tummy again
going back
same as it was earlier
so just look up what you can do with
moving more shapes rather than putting
live autism
pounding each other down